did you see that jennifer garner was
sobbing in slow motion over the office
finale
i saw that yeah it's just nice to know
you can still
just feel so much passion about
something right
so thank you if you've ever heard of
this show the office you should try it
it's it's wonderful she watched it from
the beginning with her kids and had an
extreme emotional reaction it was really
beautiful it was so great to see
her sharing that too people people just
loved it
so i just wanted to give her a big hug
but we can't hug people these days
hand hug people i feel like you guys
should do the quiz though you guys
should do the trivia together
we should that's good i would fail at
any office trivia i would be the worst
i think about this all the time because
i do a lot of like the star wars actors
interviews
and i'm always asking them questions and
like mark hamill's like i have no idea
like you guys know way much more about
this than i do
yeah yeah i watched every episode when
it first came out i haven't seen them
since and
i can't people reference episodes like i
don't even remember shooting that
how do you think dwight would be
handling quarantine i think dwight would
be
handling court quarantine by preparing
for the apocalypse
as we all should be probably safe rooms
and
ammo and canned goods
what is my perfect crime i break into
tiffany's in midnight
do i go for the vault no i go for the
chandelier it's priceless
i don't know if you've clicked around on
tick tock but there are like makeup
artists who
are doing the dwight schrute and it's
incredible
wait how are makeup artists doing the
dwight schrute i didn't even wear any
makeup
yeah no they are painting their whole
face so that they actually look like
rayne wilson as dwight schrute that is
scary that's terrifying i was very
strange looking in that in that
that little tv show yeah that's amazing
[Music]
so in quarantine i think the remaining
folk who haven't watched the office yet
they've they've watched it now so i
think the whole world has seen
do you feel like i mean have you noticed
like this resurgence in i don't know if
it's ever gone away but like in the
people talking about the office yeah so
it
the office definitely was fading away
especially during our last two or three
seasons of the show itself and
there was another two or three years
afterwards when it
was off the air we didn't really think
about it or hear about it and then
all of a sudden maybe around 2017
2018 or so it just started coming back
and
people were talking about it i was being
recognized way more being sent stuff
there were all these
memes and products and funny videos and
face mashups and and all kinds of stuff
and uh it has
it's become a global phenomenon and i
think it's brought people a lot of
comfort during some really trying times
so that's it's been great to be a part
of for that reason
i was just looking that blackberry
premiered at tiff a year ago
i was looking at my camera roll too and
tiff was exactly a year ago and it makes
me really sad that we're not there
that's right it was exactly a year ago
that's crazy
i loved watching the conversations kind
of flow around the table with just this
incredibly stacked cast
you're gonna make an excellent lawyer
someday actually i'm gonna be an actor
an actor and isn't that a damn
fine thing it is well there's plenty of
time to think about it so you know when
you read the description of the movie
you're like oh that's dark
but you watch it and it's such a sweet
movie so what would you say
to audiences like what pulled you into
it when you were reading it so blackbird
is a story about death but really it's a
story about life there is a death
at the end of the film you know it's
coming it's heart-wrenching
and at the same time it's about family
it's about laughter it's about love it's
people
coming together it's has a kind of a
wacky
weirdness to it at the same time it's
such a difficult circumstance for a
family to be having a family reunion
when they know they're losing their
matriarch
and with this incredible cast uh it's
it becomes just a really beautiful human
experience how would you explain your
character's way
of dealing with this looming death i
have to say you chopping down the
christmas tree was
a big highlight for me because that's
probably how i would behave in the woods
well my character michael is a lawyer
he's pretty
preppy he's filled with factoids and
he's married to kate winslet
somehow i don't know how that happened
camera
over here yeah really but me and leo
but uh he goes on an amazing journey you
know he's kind of a doofus at the
beginning of the film and over the
course of the film
very subtly he goes through kind of a
transformation you know he
gets to find his voice as a husband
and as a father and
uh kind of explores his sexuality even i
have a love scene with kate winslet
it's another thing i have in common with
leonardo dicaprio it was a truly
uh fun and uh brilliant journey to be a
part of
like i don't know you personally but i
feel like you and sam neil were probably
kindred spirits because like he's got
like his winery he's got all his goats
like what was it like
tell me everything about him i just love
him so much sam is like my brother from
another mother uh
he is so funny sam neil is should be
doing comedy
he is hysterical and he's got a farm
he's got goats and pigs i've got pigs
i've got a donkey and a donkey and um
there's a lot of farm jokes we have
similar taste in music
and uh we got along uh like gangbusters
and uh
boy did he make me laugh i had a hard
time keeping a straight face
with him around i love it okay tell me
about your zonkey like
how do you get a zonkey what's a zonkey
like that's a zebra donkey right like a
hype it is a zebra donkey
my wife went to zebrazarus.com i'm not
kidding you
oh and bought a zonkey and it was
delivered to our house a little baby
named derek and now derek is about five
or six years old
he is an name is derek
yeah he's he's a jerk he's a total jerk
because zonkeys have the very worst
characteristics of both
animals so all the wildness of a zebra
and all the stubbornness of a donkey
rolled into one so he's both wild and
stubborn at the same time he's a
he's a surly guy but you just love him
anyway i was gonna say it's like what
you imagine a zombie would be like
versus the reality it's like he's
exactly exactly it's a big commitment
folks
don't go buying zonkeys right and left i
want to ask you really quick about one
of my favorite movies galaxy quest
because last year it had its 20th
anniversary and
um it's one of the best movies of all
time sir i
am lank senior requisition officer
before we travel to the ship
please let me know if you have any
requirements it's somehow gotten
progressively funnier
do a lot of people reference galaxy
quest to you it comes up
uh occasionally i i was so lucky again
ash my first two movies out of the gate
and moving to los
angeles were almost famous in galaxy
quest
both of them had 20th anniversaries i
had small supporting roles in both of
them
but they're absolute classics so
what a great way to kind of pop your
cherry i know i was like speaking of
like stacked casts like you're always
you're always a part of them stacked
cast that should be in my uh instagram
bio
i also want to ask you about an idiot's
guide to climate change because i was
actually just going down the wormhole on
this
what made you want to do this this is
like coming out now during quarantine
but you filmed it before
yeah so we filmed it in the fall uh an
idiot's guide to climate change
is essentially me the idiot learning
about what's going on with climate
change
uh through a trip to greenland with a
bunch of scientists
so it's we try and make it fun it's
light it's zany
um it's a great kind of introduction to
some of the
concepts around climate change and at
the end i got to interview greta tunberg
so it was it was an amazing uh journey
and experience
yeah oh my god meeting her would be like
yeah she's a hero i mean this little
girl
sat out in front of swedish parliament
as a pre-teen with a little sign
like let's end climate change and she
started a worldwide movement
of millions tens of millions maybe
hundreds of millions of people behind
her
it's uh it's an incredible example of
[Music]
courage
you